welcome to the program Ukraine says
Russian forces have shelled a maternity
ward in cash on which is reclaimed or
which it reclaimed last month elsewhere
Ukraine's military has resumed its
counter-offensive in the Eastern region
of Lux to large cities are still under
those Russian controls while Charles
Stratford has the latest force from Kiev
let's just begin with that attack on a
hospital uh Charles just give us more
details about when and where
yeah this attack is understood happened
yesterday in her son
um shelling hitting according to the
ukrainians a Maternity Ward a
spokesperson for president zielinski
said that a doctor had literally only
just finished uh operating or giving a
Caesarean section to a pregnant mum when
this shelling started miraculously so
the spokesperson said nobody was injured
in that attack now
um this shelling comes amid seemingly an
intensification of attacks by Russian
forces from across the river across the
danipro river as you say Russian forces
withdrew from keroson November the 10th
November the 11th
um and shelling has intensified again in
the last couple of days or at least 10
people killed in an attack two three
days ago in the Center of Harrison
around 70 people injured we understand
that many of the people that have moved
back to the city in the wake of it being
liberated by Ukrainian forces are now
leaving we've also been getting details
um about some of the the areas that are
most intensely being targeted most
specifically an area called antonivica
which is directly on the banks of the
the river danipo there the Northern Bank
um Russian positions are only around 700
meters across the river
we understand certainly according to
people that we've been speaking to
inside the city there's around 8 000
people living in that district and
they're coming under heavy shelling and
are very vulnerable to sniper fire as
well so this is very interesting in as
far as does it represents a A Renewed
push or a push by Russian forces to
reach take kerison I mean I think it's
too early to say at this stage because
of course that river is such a huge
natural barrier of defense for Ukrainian
positions but this is certainly some of
the most intense shelling we've seen
since the city was liberated last month
and of course Charles you know we look
at the country as a whole and generally
we could say you know it's a tale of
perhaps small or large gains because the
fighting is intense with that
bombardment continuing sort of just
bring us up to speed on what we know has
happened overnight in other parts of the
country
well there are some very interesting
developments on the Eastern Front
um specifically the around the town of
cremina now criminal is Russian occupied
it sits very close to the lugansk
Donetsk borders
um and it was a front line that was
established there
um on the back of that very successful
counter-offensive about two and a half
months ago by ukrainians that front line
around the town of criminal hadn't moved
until a couple of days ago and now we're
getting reports from the ukrainians at
least that they are pushing forward
again
gradually taking back Villages around
criminal criminal is important basically
because if it was to be retaken by the
ukrainians it would give them a a easier
access to two of the largest cities in
Russian occupied against namely lissy
chance and sever donets now both of
those cities suffered devastating
battles and fighting last summer and
were eventually taken control of by the
Russians but yes that is significant
also with respect to the town of bakmut
now we know bakmut has seen some of the
most intense fighting in recent weeks
we've heard about probing attacks from
the Russian forces from the North and
the South of that City we are now
hearing certainly according to Pro
Russia telegram channels they are
advocating that Russian forces should
actually withdraw because the situation
has become so untenable for them now of
course we cannot anyway independently
verify these kind of lines but in
support of that kind of line of
reporting The american-based Institute
the studies of war is reporting that um
Russian units or Russian forces around
back moot have been some have been
pulled back they're now going down
towards described as a small kind of
tactical units
um now is W are saying this is a similar
kind of thing to what happened in the
build up to Russia's withdrawal Russian
forces withdrawal from her son but
military analysts will say this could
just be a winter tactic withdrawing
trying to pull troops back to better
protect them in the winter months and
artillery further back Russian Artillery
attacks on Bahamut will continue but as
I say a lot of moving Parts in the East
and the South today
um some some certainly for the Ukrainian
perspective some encouraging news there
Charles Stratford voice that in key
thank you
now Russian President Vladimir Putin has
banned oil exports to countries that set
price caps on his Energy Products now
the decree will come into effect in
February and will last for at least five
months earlier this month the EU
Australia and the Group of Seven agreed
to cap Russian crude at sixty dollars a
barrel the aim is to restrict moscow's
Revenue while still supplying the global
market
many countries have pledged to end or
reduce their dependence on Russian
energy since it invaded Ukraine energy
exports account for around 40 percent of
Russia's annual revenue and are worth
around a billion dollars a day Russia
says the cap under the sanctions won't
affect its military offensive in Ukraine
Moscow is confident it can find new
buyers countries such as India and China
are still buying Russian oil Thomas
O'Donnell is an energy analyst and
lecturer at the herty school of
governance in Berlin he says Russia's
oil revenues have already taken a hit
you have outstanding Unity of the entire
EU G7 and so forth very broadly on an
agreement to very harshly sanction
Russian oil the EU is taking no more oil
by sea since the fifth of this month and
by the 5th of February they won't take
any more refined products by sea from
Russia that's a stunning hit to Russia
and now they will enforce this price cap
worldwide anybody who wants to use any
ships insured from the European Union
will have to re you know respect this
and already I know I was watching
looking at Bloomberg's latest data a day
or two ago and the shipments from Russia
and the European side the Baltic area
had dropped by 50 percent in the early
part of December when this cap was
imposed so is this in fact bravado from
Putin or we're going to cut supplies
when they're already being forced to
have a significant hit to their supplies